notre reporter reste elle cherche et
celle bonjour alors contrairement à
l'aéroport d'orly l'activité à roissy
charles de gaulle n'a jamais était à
l'arrêt quelle est la situation à
l'heure actuelle et bien à les portes du
terminal 2f sont ouvertes comme vous
pouvez peut-être le voir derrière moi
doha mais très peu de passage ici
puisque l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle est quasiment à désert et cela
depuis plusieurs semaines on vous
l'avait dit il est resté ouvert pendant
toute cette période de confinement un
trafic minimale a été maintenue ici avec
seulement trois terminaux d'opérationnel
ici une quinzaine de vols va être opéré
ce jour alors pour garantir un maximum
de sécurité aussi sa vie milla passagers
qui transitent tout de même ici à roissy
en des dispositions ont été apprises le
port du masque est obligatoire pour
entrer dans le terminal dans les salles
d'attentes un siège sur deux a été
condamné est ce qui permet de respecter
aller distanciation sociale et puis les
comptoirs d'enregistrement ont été
équipée de vitres en plexiglas pourrait
limiter les contacts et puis enfin il ya
ce fameux marquage au sol auquel nous
sommes habitués maintenant qui a été
apposée dans les files d'attentes pour
respecter les uns m 2 est distant le
déconfinement ne devrait donc pas avoir
vraiment d'incidence ici à roissy 1
puisque le trafic aérien
devrait rester encore perturbé ces
prochaines semaines estelle farges en
direct de l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle merci pour toutes ces précisions